am i doing better at making thumbnails
for videos
i'm trying to
oh gosh every every time there's someone
who has a video that talks about the
truth
it's usually
it's usually garbage and is is what i
found
but it seems to attract a lot of clicks
and views so i'm like well
when in rome
i guess this is the thing that youtube
does now so you have to have like
click bait thumbnails and click bait
titles
anyway
uh
yeah today we're going to learn about
this weird plant
we're going to learn the truth about
that weird plan but first i just wanted
to point out i um i just got a new book
it's my life
a record of events and opinion from
alfred russell wallace and for those who
don't know
wallace
co-discovered natural selection with
darwin
darwin was working on his book
and wallace actually wrote him a letter
where he described the process of
natural selection and this new idea that
he had he was asking darwin what he
thought of it because i guess there was
some
some
some word on the street that uh that
darwin was interested in in ideas about
evolution
and that kind of like
jolted darwin and got him excited that
he should probably uh you know he should
probably participate or quickly publish
his book
so it's really interesting that the
theory of evolution by natural selection
was actually discovered independently by
two different people and probably if it
weren't for darwin or wallace it would
have been discovered again what what i
think had happened
is that we were in a we were just in a
big
um
we were at this moment in history when
there was so much
biodiversity that was understood and
collected it was in museums and then
people were going around and traveling
around the world that the theory of
evolution was just inevitable it was
just going to be understood
what what evolution requires is a as an
understanding of biodiversity and that
biodiversity was it was
being discovered at this time
so wallace discovered it darwin
discovered it darwin ended up writing a
better book about it
he really really fleshed out the idea
and so he's the one that history has
remembered it's also probably because of
his wealth and so on wallace
i haven't read the book yet but i'm
pretty sure he was fairly like
uneducated or was he wasn't
he wasn't like officially educated so he
was um he was well read but he wasn't
he didn't like have a you know
doctorate degree or something
and
darwin on the other hand was really well
connected within the scientific
community so he was able to to do a lot
more in in reaching the scientific
community
so that's interesting
but
i the reason i bought this book is
because i've been hearing a lot of
people complain that we don't give
wallace enough credit for his
contribution to the theory of evolution
and so i got this book and it's really
funny because this book itself like
you can't really see in the screen here
but
this photograph of wallace is all
pixelated so even like the book that
about him that i bought i paid money for
they couldn't trouble themselves to
like go and actually get a high quality
like version of his photograph for the
cover of the book they just apparently
took it off wikipedia or something so i
thought that was funny
uh it really is true that this guy is
not getting enough credit
for his discovery so anyway that's a
that's a very
that's a tangent
today we want to
discover
what's going on with this plant here so
i've got some pictures of it just a
refresher especially for anyone who may
have not
seen the video the first part of this
series so i found this plant
growing in
most most of it was growing out of water
this particular one was growing out of a
a bit of a pond that had dried up so it
had been growing in water but the water
receded
and
it's a really really interesting plant
it's got these so
i'm showing you the spike ball here so
this is these are all the seeds and
they've already been fertilized they've
already been pollinated and then here we
see
what it looks like when it's
not so mature you've got all those seeds
that are starting to butt out there and
you have all these little
flower balls
and what i had concluded my tentative
conclusion in the field
you know one of the things that we want
to try and figure out here is
how does this thing reproduce are each
of these little orbs are they going to
turn into a spiky ball full of seeds or
are those male flowers and these are the
female flowers that was one of the
questions that we had
and in the field there i had concluded
that all of these must turn into
seed pods
and i
did start to doubt that later when i got
home and started looking at all the
footage
and then so here's what
here's what uh
one of these things looks like early on
and my thought was that
these
actually turn into those spikes the
other possibilities that these might
just have pollen and the spike balls
might just be the female part of the
plant so it's got a male flower and a
female
flower here we have these those puffball
flowers the flowers when they're still
in puffball form the flower clusters i
should say
so yes the question is what species is
this
are its flowers hermaphroditic so is
each flower both male and female or are
some male and some female that's also
common in plants and then the third
question that i asked the audience is
will spike husks
open to drop seeds or will the seed
cluster simply break apart
so
those are the questions that i had there
feel free to
you know chime in on the comments here
as we're
as we're
going along
i'm going to
pull up the video because there's a lot
of comments people left on that video
itself so
here is the video from last week
and
down here we had a lot of people
responding to my three questions
uh
biophile
i don't know if biophile is a guy or gal
but uh biofile
tells us that they are a botanist
and
that they have not looked this up
because that was the thing you can't
look it up you can't google it you gotta
just know off the top of your head if
you happen to know what species this is
awesome off the top of your head and
biofile gives us a guess
and one of the most interesting things
said here let me just read this part
down here
definitely distinct male and female
flowers the fluffy ones are male the
spiky ones are female the female flowers
have a divided stigma the white spikes
which drop off
which means they probably have two
carpels per flower in the cluster
probably only one seed develops
in each though
so that was pretty interesting
and then they also say that uh
they probably the the the seed capsules
probably don't open up and drop their
seeds when they're ready they're
probably the whole thing just probably
breaks apart
and so that that was interesting and we
have some some other people giving
conflicting guesses here so i want to go
through some of these well
most of them here
karen says i have other plants that
flower first then develop seed pods or
clusters like this one
i gotta i got a complaint dude high pass
filter i'm listening on my home audio
system and the wind noise makes the
walls shake
so first off
thanks for the feedback i probably
should have done a little bit more to
edit that audio but also i
don't you think it's kind of interesting
that i was out in the wilderness on a on
a warm calm summer day and that calm
summer breeze went through my little
microphone on my camera
and
was transmitted to your house and
actually shook the walls of your house
that little gentle summer breeze made
your house
shake and uh
caused you a little bit of suffering
triggering you to write that comment i i
just think that's somehow interesting so
anyway
uh we gotta we got another comment i
don't know if they're being serious or
if this is a joke i think jesus did it
that doesn't really
respond to my questions
the things there at all
then we got a a quote from a book here
about the morning star
which is a little bit off topic
derek writes
how are this more interestingly how are
the seeds dispersed not wind not edible
not caught on animal for waterborne
but looks very congested in that
locality in the locality so that that's
that's a really good thing to think
about like how are these spiky seeds
uh passed around i did get a couple
people saying that maybe the spikes
suggested they are caught in fur
actually okay j right right below says
the fact that the seeds are on a tall
stalk and are covered with spikes
suggests to me that they get caught
in the fur of animals like stinging
nettles the animals then clean
themselves near a water source possibly
by getting in the water
i because the seeds are so big i don't
think that's likely i mean they're huge
and the the spikes are actually they're
not very sharp let me pull up that
slides again
um
if i show you the images here
that
you can see that
the
yeah those spikes really couldn't get
caught in anything's fur i don't think
so yeah i don't think that that's
possible i don't know if there's you
know this fruit is edible
i actually i have looked things up now
by the way i am now
informed with legitimate information but
i'm not sure i really didn't hear much
if i did hear that some
birds will eat the seeds but i didn't i
don't know if the fruit around the seeds
is what they're after are there after
the seeds themselves it's kind of
interesting so there certainly is a
little bit of animal dispersal going on
here but we'll we'll see what the main
dispersal source is in a moment
so
back to
youtube comments
more interestingly how are the seeds
okay we already read that okay
my guess is that it is a species of
water chestnut and the seed is is
spread by sticking to waterfowl
need some more data i'm thinking the
spike ball is the pollinated seed
bearing part of the plant they don't
look like they would attach to animals
to be carried away but maybe they
dissuade animals from eating the seeds
yeah i i don't think that that's even
possible i think the spike is just
the spike i think is just kind of a
remnant of the the flowering part it's
i think of this like um
you know like the the little
part on the end of an apple the little
flowery looking part on the end of an
apple
that's just
the remains of the flower i think that's
what the spikes are in this case they're
just the remains of the flower i don't i
don't know that they're really an
adaptation to stop predation or anything
uh
okay i don't know
might be the
sparganium a rectum but it seems that
there are many subspecies of similar
plant
uh that's
you are very close by the way
it's paul on until paul uh
it's pollination until pollen tube
reaches the ovum then it's fertilization
given the yellow granular looking tips
and the bee so remember in in the video
there's a bee that was uh collecting
pollen from those those flowers the
flowers certainly seem to have pollen
producing aspect and given that we have
pretty clear evidence of insect
pollination and that that occurs when
insects already covered in pollen are
attracted to get more
from another flower
and transfer it i would agree that the
flowers have both male and female
components so this guy is in in in
conflict with the uh botanist two who
chimed in uh earlier
and this guy is thinking along the lines
that i was thinking of originally which
i started to doubt later on when i was
looking at the at the footage
as to the round balls i had originally
thought that they were
fertile flowers having dropped their
petals stamen etc
but after seeing the semi-spike ball
phase with some petals still attached
i don't know what to think as for the
spike balls themselves i wonder if they
may use the type of seed dispersal that
uses heat
on incredibly hot days to cause them to
burst
and throw the seeds widely
i also wonder if there is any notable
animals attracted to them that the
spikes may
maybe to inhibit
uh i want to just just comment on on
that real quick
there actually were i didn't get footage
of them but there were there was a plant
right next to this plant it was it had
like a bean type stock on it and those
ones are the ones that if you touch them
yet they weren't quite ready which is
one of the reasons i didn't film it
but if you hit them they burst open in
the seeds fling everywhere and it's
really cool there's a lot of plants that
do this they when the seed pod dries it
dries in a way that it causes tension so
that if you just barely bump it the
seeds explode
all over the place that's a really cool
adaptation for seed dispersal
and
these ones do not do that however
as as we'll find out in just a moment
yeah i got some more confirmation
sparganium
erectum sparganium the genus is actually
correct turns out
but that species is
fairly unlikely that's what what i'm
finding i actually still don't have 100
certainty
uh because
but
actually i'm sure that it's not uh the a
rectum species now but we'll go into
that in a moment
is it just coincident that coincidence
that the spiky seed things you found
were all near the base of the stem
no it's not actually
while the pollen and flowers were
further out because it does seem likely
to me that those pollen areas at the
very ends would develop into the
presumably heavy seeds
sorry it doesn't seem likely but i know
nothing about this topic so yeah though
you're you were in the position that i
was in early on like i
yeah i wasn't sure
a keysight channel comments he's he's
given me species possibilities
and by the way it seems to me that you
looked this up my friend
i i know you said that you you just
learned about this in in
seventh grade
and plant reproduction but i find it i
find it suspicious that they would have
taught you the specific species names of
plants that this might be
but
you you say that you think it's a burr
reed and it's not hermaphroditic in the
sense that the flowers are both male and
female you think that they are it's it's
monacis
so you got female and male separate
flowers but on the same plant so the
plant itself is hermaphroditic but the
flowers are not
here uh
selena selena
selena i'm i'm horrible pronouncing
people's names i apologize i'm also
really bad at pronouncing uh
the
the uh scientific names as
has been pointed out many times on this
channel
i've never seen this plant before it
reminds me somewhat of sedges they have
separate male and female flowers and
creates spiky seed pods
this is similar to those yeah
i think the big fluffy flowers the bee
was visiting were male flowers the
female flowers are the ones that are the
tiny spike balls with the pollen
receptors
yes that's a very good
hypothesis
i think the spiky ball will stay
attached to the plant each spike will
split open and one seed will fall out of
each spike
let's see
thanks first thing i did was crack open
my field guide to wildflowers north
america
i'm going to consider that cheating so
i'm going to skip over that one but yeah
that person was correct they found it in
a book not in google and i didn't
specifically mention not to use books i
said not to use google so i mean i guess
yeah i'm going to consider that cheating
but we'll we'll
uh
not intentional cheating
um
sorry
some of these are too long for me to
read
um
but
this one here we had we had quite a few
people talk about
um trees
that are doing this
and of course this is not a tree it's
not really closely related it was the i
think people are saying it was a gum
tree
and it you know it's not but
it is very very similar
in seed pods they do look very similar i
think that's just
convergence
let's see
seems the spike flowers have
we're getting repetitive here now so i
think it's
fair to just dig into
what it was that i found
and
let me start that by
just
i've got a little video that i filmed i
actually found one of the seed pods that
was ready to
like basically ready to go
let me let me look real quick if i've
got any questions in the live comments
here
we got we got more people watching good
let me go to my slides
this is where i stored the video for you
all
so again here's my
my pictures so here here we finally
found one that is ready to fall apart so
yeah the sea
seeds they just
crumble
crumble into the water
individual seeds look like that
so yeah they just dangle over the water
drop in
float away
they're kind of they're fairly soft and
filled with air
at this point
so they
they float
here
our third question will the spike husks
open and drop seeds or will the seed
cluster simply break apart
so that that question is answered they
just kind of break apart and
it reminded me a lot of corn on the cob
but the cob was just a little tiny
sphere in the middle so that i don't
know that was kind of neat so it's
individual kernels and they just fall
apart when they're ready
so that's how this plant works that's
that's how its seeds are dispersed and
when i was reading about this online the
these this whole genus they
the seeds are dispersed through the
water they float around they're
dispersed that way
they'll eventually sink and they can
stay submerged for it's like
i think it's
like up to five years before they
actually grow that that they they're
triggered to grow by the right amount of
sun so they you know they're underwater
and there has to be the right right
amount of sunlight to trigger them to
grow and they can stay
under water without the water damaging
them for up to five years this was a
research done
because this this species is actually a
problem for people who are growing rice
it'll actually grow and choke out the
rice so people who are trying to deal
with this plant they're trying to study
everything about how it works and that's
where i got all the really cool
information
about
how this thing works
it's people trying to kill it which is
interesting this is how we learn about
most
whenever we know a lot about an
individual species it's usually because
we we've been at war with it for one
reason or another which i don't know
maybe that's sad maybe that's
interesting
um
i
it's just how it is
okay
so
i i made a video of me
trying to figure out what kind of plant
this was
and i don't know
how interesting this is going to be to
people
let me just go ahead and play it here
i am actually going to try and figure
out
i'm going to turn the volume up here
what type of plant that is using a
google image search this is
the first thing that i do whenever i see
a weird animal or plant i know there are
apps nowadays that you can get for your
phone you usually have to pay for them
but where you can just like take a
picture of a plant and it will identify
it i don't have one of those i'm not
that cool
so i just go here and i'm going to type
in
i should point out i just pause it i
should point out that you actually don't
need one of those apps now google glass
can do it i should have just uploaded
photos that i had taken
or is it google glass i can't google
lens i think is what it's called
um
so you can actually just upload your own
pictures and i could look there's
there's actually a little camera icon
right there i could have just uploaded
my own picture
and google would try to id the plan for
me but i didn't do that i'm using the
old school method here
uh where i'm just going through
doing a google search
so
and
this by the way
i i do think that this might be helpful
for people to see how i do google
searches because
it's
i have to do this all the time for
obscure things because i teach biology
and uh
a lot of the things that i'm that i'm
interested in a lot of the questions
that i have there's not
i'll just see something and i'll have a
question about it and i won't have any
of the vocabulary and so i do a lot of
google image searching and just
like just browsing online and so maybe i
think i will show you the rest of this
video even though i did this in it in
sort of an inefficient way because
it'll it'll just show you my chaotic
method for doing this
so
robotic plant spike seeds
and see
what comes up here
i think that's too general
nothing here really
really does it for me
that's too general well it also looked
it had this um the morning star which
let me try typing in morningstar
uh let's
that looks similar oh
there we go
that
looks exactly like
like what what we're looking for let me
let me
so anyway that that was
that was me starting out what i'm what i
usually try and do when i'm googling is
i just try to basically google so good
right now that
if you just
word things how you would word it if you
were just trying to describe what you
saw to someone else
just type that into google and you will
most likely find it so you know i i
noticed these things look like the
morning star mace
weapons that the germans used to use
and so i just assumed that other people
would describe it that way as well and
that was
it was adding that little word morning
star that that allowed me to find this
plant i eventually found the species you
know i
eventually went to ended up finding the
wikipedia page for the genus
and i was able to go through all the
different
little wikipedia pages and find photos
that looked most like the species
that i was looking into and then i was
able to look that species up in the
scientific literature and learn all
sorts of things about it you know
and the species that i ended up finding
this
and
i'm not 100 sure that i'm right but i'm
close to 100 sure at this point because
i actually got descriptions of
of of this plant and how to distinguish
it from the the plants that are most
common to it i was able to find some
really cool
information
for for uh you know
figuring out what species this is and it
turns out
i am act
that the species is sparganium
urecarpum that
is the species
so it's the common name is the giant bur
reed
so both of these questions have now been
not been solved what species is it will
spike husks open to drop seeds or will
the seed cluster simply break apart but
what about its flowers
the are the flowers hermaphroditic
well each one of those little
ball here let me go back to the
photos here will each one of these
little
will this ball here turn into a spike
ball
so here's you know will it will it go
from this to something that looks like
this to something that looks like this
is that the progression or
is this little puffy ball a completely
different type of flower than this one
here or then than this one here
and the answer is they are
different flowers this
species has both male flowers
and female flowers they're actually
flower clusters so each
each of these
is the pistol
so the the female part the a female
flower
so each each of these here you actually
have the the ends of the flower are
still on there so these these little
white tips here those can receive pollen
and when they do the
[Music]
you know the egg cell inside will be
fertilized
a little seed inside will be fertilized
and they will develop
so this is what we're seeing here is
actually the the ovary
of the the flower the fruit of the
flower
it's got that seed inside that's
starting to grow now that it's been
fertilized and eventually
you get to
a giant
seed cluster like this so that means
that these these male flowers here these
are the uh what do you call them the
stamen here these just produce pollen
and that's it
and there's a
you know i ended up finding this in the
literature but
the
everybody who mentioned this i couldn't
actually get a really good description
of this online i would have had to go to
the library
and the library in my city didn't have
the book that i needed because there
actually is
a description a full detailed
description of this plant of its anatomy
of its flowers that's from like the
1800s
and it's a pretty hard book to find
and it's not online
but i did find a bunch of scientific
papers that were referring to it and
then they would kind of gloss over this
stuff but they would refer to that book
but they glossed over in a way that was
detailed enough for me to to know that
that this is
um
in fact a male flower and the other is a
female flower
and more specifically
i am
we have um
so it's called a
monitious plant so you've got it it's
hermaphro the plant itself is
hermaphroditic so it's both male and
female but
we have separate flowers
and that is in contrast to just a
regular hermaphroditic flower it's also
sometimes called a perfect flower where
it's both male and female
and the male parts are usually below the
female part so they can't accidentally
fertilize their own flower
and then you have diocese
plants which
the there's a specific male plant in the
specific female plant probably the most
common plants like this that everyone
would know would be the holly plants
holly plants are usually either male or
female
you know the little spiky leaves and the
the red fruits
and then the other plant that's really
common is that everyone knows about is
marijuana marijuana is either male or
female and so if the the
the one that people use to smoke i think
is
i can't remember what is it i think it's
the it's the female one is the one that
has the buds on it that people then
smoke
so
yeah it's interesting so this this
website right here
talks about you know it it references
the scientific literature but it talked
about it in the most obvious way this
was the
um
missouri missouri wild man i i
should have had the url up on here
but
it's a missouri's
like state
website for their own plants
and it looks like it was
someone's blog from the 90s
but it actually has really good
information in the yeah
so it's telling us that these are uh
flower clusters each of these little
balls is a flower cluster
and it talks about the
the
stamina heads so these are the stamen
the male the male flowers and then these
are the female flowers the pistolate
heads
the female flower cluster and what's
really interesting
so this is this is a monitious plant
what's really interesting about this is
that the
the male parts are above the female
parts
and what that tells us is that even
though we saw
a bug
an insect and we saw a bee that was
collecting pollen
their main
method of pollination is
self-pollination by wind self
pollination in the pollination of
neighbors by wind
so the the male part is above the female
part
and i saw by the way i saw some stocks
that had
up to two female flowers on one stock
and then the males would start but most
of them just had one female and then it
was just males all the way up
so there was that there was some
diversity among the same species in that
in that respect
but
this works you know i said i said
earlier that that it's shaped kind of
like
it it looks sort of like corn
and that the uh
the
these seeds are attached to a little
uh kind of a corn cob but it's a round
corn cob instead of a rod shaped corn
cob but you know this is the way that
corn pollinates as well corn is mainly
wind pollinated
and you've got the male part of the
flower that sticks up above the corn and
you have the the actual the ears of corn
are the female parts so we just eat the
female
part of the
of the plant
so yeah some really cool similarities
there
so yes all of our questions are answered
that is the truth
about
uh
you
know this plant that i found so
what's it wednesday everybody
i'm not gonna do this every week i'm not
gonna do a what's it wednesday every
week but there are a bunch of other
what's it wednesday videos
that are actually not plant related
they're all they're all about skulls
actually the all the other ones are but
i will do this from time to time when i
find a weird thing
out in the wild i'll throw up a what's
it wednesday video
i thought this was fun i don't know if
you guys
uh
liked this as much as i did but i
thought it was really cool to do
and it was fun to have all the
interactions that i got
underneath that video we had something
like 45 people chimed in on what they
thought it was and people were playing
the game they were actually doing it um
sweet gum yeah people were um a.a was
asking if as i was talking about sweet
gum
no this is not sweet gum but a lot of
people thought that it was because it
has very similar seed pods so
i'm getting some some information about
marijuana here
marijuana has hermaphrodites
female hemp plant can actually grow male
flowers under stress too that's
interesting it's really interesting that
it's that it's when it's stressed i i
really like these these um
conditional adaptations that so many
organisms have that that don't show up
very often even in entire individuals
my my wife and i were just talking about
this the other night we were talking
about um
the way that we behave in emergency
situations
we were talking about driving in this
case there was a horrible car accident
in our in our um
not in our neighborhood but in our city
and she's she's a nurse and she helped
work on it and it was well
she wasn't working on it but she she saw
what what happened and it was absolutely
horrifying
but there was a guy who
ran to the scene of this accident
and just immediately opened up a
vehicle that was completely in flames he
just
dove in there and pulled a guy out who
was unconscious
and we were talking about this
this um
it's it's an instinctual drive that we
have
that gets triggered where
when you're in a crazy situation you
either run away from it and actually one
of the other drivers that was in this
accident he ran away his instinct
was to run away it's this this fight or
flight thing you know his instinct was
to run away and i think i don't know if
he came back to the scene later
but
he immediately ran away maybe it was his
the accident was his fault or maybe he
was just he just
there was an accident and then
everything was in flames and so he ran
away to get away from his car
but
someone someone else their instinct was
to run towards it and to try and help
out and i i think this is just really
interesting
because i've been in situations like
this before
and it's like you're observing yourself
it's like you are not in control you're
just doing something and i i happen to
be one of the idiots that runs and
runs in
to the scenes
actually not always i actually did
when i was in los
las vegas once someone was beating up a
mascot and i just
i just uh
i wasn't i wasn't very close there was a
lot of other people that were closer
that should have been the ones to break
it up and my instincts were to just kind
of
watch but in other cases i've i've put
myself in stupid dangerous situations
where afterwards i'm like why did i do
that i've got
i've broken up dog fights before like
between two dogs i've also broken up
fights between a
person being attacked by a dog
when i was in brazil
and
all of these times it was completely
instinctual it was not i was not in
control it was i was just going and
doing it
and i think that's really interesting
that we have these um these adaptations
that might not ever even be useful at
all in your lifetime but they're there
and what a certain
like stimuli
certain things will trigger you into
action and you're just doing stuff that
makes no sense
and this these the
that the marijuana plants can do that
too that's really interesting that when
they're under stress they will grow both
male and female
flowers
which allows them to pollinate
themselves
and reproduce even though they might not
uh otherwise be able to find a mate
which this tells us that there's for
some reason there is an evolutionary
pressure
for hemp
to
to reproduce sexually and to never
self-fertilize
unless
times are really really rough so i think
that's cool that's really cool
in my opinion
well
thank you everyone for joining in on the
live
show
this is a lot of fun
uh
so long for now
stay curious